Prof: Okay.
Now we're going to talk about a
different kind of ecology.
We're going to talk about the
flow of energy and matter
through ecosystems.
Up until now we have been
dealing mostly with the
biological interactions of
organisms with each other,
with organisms of other
species, and with some
physiological ecology where
they're dealing with the
physical and chemical problems
presented by the environment.
But now we're going to look at
the energy and flow of materials
through ecosystems and biomes,
and in the world as a whole,
as a paradigm that's driven
primarily by physics and
chemistry.
Now there are differences
between ecosystem and community
ecology, and I think that
this--you know,
some of this is a little bit
light-hearted;
some of it is dead serious.
So in ecosystem ecology,
one is primary concerned about
the flow of matter and energy,
and in community ecology
primarily with inter-specific
interactions.
The paradigm here is
thermodynamics.
So the mass balance equations,
the second law,
entropy increases,
things like that.
Here the issues are primarily
competition, predation and
history, and space.
Okay?
The kinds of measurements that
get made are physical,
chemical and geological here,
and they're biological here.
So you don't see Latin names
and you don't see species names
in ecosystem ecology;
and they are definitely present
and they're important in
community ecology.
The way that scientists chunk
reality in order to make it
manageable is quite different.
In ecosystem ecology,
they worry about ecosystem
compartments and stuff that
moves between them,
and in community ecology they
worry mostly about species
abundances and how it changes in
time and space.
So the connection here is
primarily to the biosphere.
Here people are looking upward
at larger, more complicated,
bigger kinds of things;
and in the community ecology
they're mostly looking downward
at how the community
interactions are driving the
population dynamics of the
individual species.
So the connection here is to
biology and the connection here
is to geology.
And the two things definitely
connect to each other,
okay?
So they have strong
implications for each other.
But, as you know,
academic specialties themselves
evolve,
and people develop different
paradigms and different language
for dealing with problems,
and they have tended to remain
isolated from one another,
and, unfortunately,
sometimes they have even tended
to denigrate one another,
although they're both perfectly
valid ways of trying to analyze
the world;
they're really just trying to
answer different questions.
So today what I'm going to do
is I'm just going to outline
energy flow, cycles of materials
and biogeochemical cycles
through ecosystems.
I'm dealing with it at a fairly
descriptive level.
There are methods of making
this paradigm very quantitative.
And if you get interested in
it, really the place to go is
geology.
Ruth Blake does this kind of
thing.
She's a biogeochemist in
geology.
This is a part of the world
that has important implications
for global warming,
and which is driven mostly by
things that have one cell.
Okay?
Whether they're algae or
bacteria, they are the main
transducer between life and
geology.
Now what is an ecosystem?
Well it's one of those sort of
abstract terms that gets
operationalized in a lot of
different ways,
depending on who's doing the
study.
But generally speaking it's the
organisms in a particular place,
plus the physical and chemical
environment with which they're
interacting.
And it's often a local example
of some kind of biome.
Okay?
So it could be a local chunk of
tundra, a local chunk of
rainforest, a pond.
It could be an upwelling area
off Peru.
It could be an alpine forest.
It could be a lot of different
things.
And people study how energy
flows,
and so the paradigm basically,
at least for things that are in
the part of the planet that are
driven by the primary
productivity of plants,
it starts with photosynthesis,
and the annual production is
usually determined by
temperature and moisture;
certainly for terrestrial
ecosystems.
Left out of this description is
all of the chemosynthetic
activity which occurs in deep,
black, dark water at mid-ocean
ridges,
and which is occurring in the
subterranean part of the
biosphere that goes down- up to
say five or ten kilometers,
where there are bacteria that
are living deep in the ground.
And actually the pervasive
influx of life,
into the subterranean
environment, is an important
part in the biogeochemistry of
the planet;
that's not covered here.
If we look around by,
just by surface area,
the planet's about 65% open
ocean;
it's about 5% continental shelf;
desert's about 5%--that's
extreme desert,
okay, that's just about nothing
on the surface;
semidesert, so Sahel,
that kind of area,
about almost 3½,
4%;
3% tropical rainforest;
and so forth.
The idea here is you can take
the planet and you can define
different categories of the way
things live on it,
just by surface area,
and break it down,
and it looks like this.
So here, if you were just to
look at that,
you would say, "Well,
open ocean, continental shelf,
desert and rainforest are the
main biomes on the planet."
That's just by surface area.
If you look at net primary
production per square meter,
you get a totally different
view.
Okay?
So this is just by surface
area, and this is by primary
production per square meter.
Look at how lousy the open
oceans are.
Open oceans are deserts.
Why are open oceans deserts?
Student:  No fresh water.
Prof: What?
Prof: No,
it's not that there's no fresh
water.
What do you need if you're
going to make an ecosystem
productive?
Student:  Zooplankton
>.
Prof: They need
nutrients.
Where are they going to get it?
Student:  Weathering
or--
Prof: They could get it
from weathering or they could
get it from upwelling.
Where does upwelling occur?
Student: On a costal
reef.
Prof: Yeah,
continental margins.
Get out in the middle of the
ocean and there's actually a
tremendous amount of fertilizer
there but it's five miles down,
three to five miles down,
and you just can't get it up.
It's sealed off,
because the top of the ocean is
warm and the bottom of the ocean
is cold,
and there's no way that cold
water can come up through warm
water,
unless you have Coriolis force
or wind or something like that
driving it.
So that's why the open oceans
are deserts.
You'll notice that tropical
rainforests are highly
productive per square meter.
In general forests are pretty
productive.
Swamps and streams are very
Algal beds and reefs are quite
productive, and so are
estuaries.
So if you want to go someplace
where you're--
you know, you're a naturalist,
you like creepy-crawlies,
you want frogs in your pocket,
you want to see something new
for Christmas,
you go to these places;
that's where you'll see a lot
of stuff.
Okay?
So right there you already know
where the prospecting is good,
if you like to see lots of
biodiversity.
Now if you look at percent
contribution to global primary
production,
the open oceans again crop up,
and that is because there's
just so darn much of them.
If you're out there in space,
looking at the world,
you realize that you can fit
all of the continents into the
Pacific Ocean;
it's bigger than all the
continents put together.
And most of it is open ocean;
most of it is low primary
productivity open ocean.
But there's just so darn much
of it that on the planetary
scale it's making a pretty good
contribution.
And the tropical rainforests
are big enough so that even
though they're only 3 and a half
or 4% of the globe,
they have such high primary
productivity that they're
kicking in quite a bit.
And the others,
even though they are
productive, occupy such a small
portion of the globe that
they're not contributing that
much.
Okay, so this is an overall
view of energy flow on the
planet, at least for the
photosynthetically driven part
of the planet.
The sun is sending in the
energy.
And by the way,
any idea of roughly how much of
the sunlight that comes into the
planet is actually captured by
life?
How efficient has the planet
become at capturing photons?
Does it capture 50%,
10%, 1%, 1/10^(th) of a
percent?
A guess?
How many for 50% Hands up.
How many for 10%?
Hands up.
A couple.
How many for 1%?
Hands up.
How many for 1/10^(th) of a
percent?
Hands up.
See the grad students think
it's a 1/10^(th) of a percent.
It's a small amount.
I don't know the precise
number, but it's down between
1/10 and 1% I think.
So even after 3.5 billion years
of evolutionary history,
the planet has not become
terribly efficient at capturing
sunlight.
Freeman Dyson has got this
definition of different kinds of
civilizations.
One of the stages of
civilization would be when you
can put a sphere around an
entire solar system and capture
all of the photons coming off of
the sun and harness it for
running a civilization.
That would capture the entire
solar output.
Well, you know,
we are a tiny little dot on the
face of the sun,
and we're taking 1/10^(th) to
1% of its photons.
So this isn't a very big number
when you look at the solar
output.
What happens is that basically
algae, primarily algae,
but also trees and all other
larger plants,
are capturing this.
Then the herbivores are eating
the plants.
The primary carnivores are
eating the herbivores.
The secondary carnivores are
eating the primary carnivores.
What do you think is in the red
arrows, going off to the
detritivores?
In simple Anglo-Saxon,
four letter words,
what do you think is in the red
arrow?
Shit and corpses.
Okay?
That's the red arrow.
It's pretty big.
Any idea what Africa would look
like if you got rid of the dung
beetles?
You would need hip-waders;
especially in the Serengeti or
any of the big national parks.
A pile of elephant dung is
about this big.
Okay?
So that's what's going off in
here.
We are deeply indebted to dung
beetles.
>
Believe me.
And to fungi.
What's going off here is
respiration.
So that's energy.
You know, you all use it up
every day.
You're using up somewhere
between oh 3500 and 5000
calories a day,
depending on whether you're on
a sports team or not.
And so that's what's going off
out here.
And this is coming off of every
level here.
Okay?
So you can think of this as
what's left over and this is the
flow of all that ATP driven
stuff on the planet surface.
Now how does that look in space?
Well if you look at tons of
carbon fixed per hectare per
year,
where green is a lot and yellow
is a little,
you can see that the forests
are really important.
Okay?
And the closer you get to the
equator and the wetter it gets,
the more efficient the forests
are at fixing carbon.
This is for the terrestrial
part of the world.
If you could put the reefs in,
they would be fixing carbon,
and they would be withdrawing
it on kind of a different
timescale.
Because the tropical forests,
although they fix a lot of
carbon, don't actually cleanse
the atmosphere of CO2,
at least not at equilibrium.
Why not?
Student: As they're
>
they're actually they're also
respiring.
Prof: They are
respiring, yes.
What happens to a tree when it
dies?
Student:  It releases a
lot of carbon.
Prof: It releases a lot
of carbon, right?
So in fact you could grow up a
big forest but you only get the
carbon benefit the first time
you grow it up;
after that it goes into an
equilibrium where the trees are
falling down and the logs are
rotting and they're releasing
carbon back into the atmosphere.
So yes, you can temporarily fix
a lot of carbon by planting a
lot of trees,
but in the long run it's not a
stable solution because those
trees get burned up;
they either get literally
burned up, or they get
metabolized by the detritivores,
and the detritivores put the
carbon back into the system.
What happens when you fix
carbon in a reef?
You make limestone,
and limestone sticks around for
a long time.
And if you take a big reef and
you slam it into a continent
with a tectonic collision,
you get marble.
So the marble quarries of the
world are the fixed carbon of 3
to 500 million years ago.
So you can actually tie up
carbon for a much longer period
more stably by putting it into
limestone than you can by
putting it into wood.
However, there are also some
important things about different
kinds of forests and how well
they can grow,
and a lot depends upon whether
you have a deciduous tree or a
conifer.
And if you look around the
world at the different kinds of
forests,
it turns out that the
coniferous forests can actually
fix more carbon per year than a
deciduous forest,
basically because they keep on
growing at times when the
deciduous trees have dropped
their leaves.
Okay?
So their primary productivity,
in terms of tons of carbon per
hectare per year,
is about 1 and a half that of a
deciduous forest.
And I mention that because
there are--
these are the kinds of
broad-scale biological
differences that are important
to pay attention to if you're
doing ecosystem ecology.
There are some that you can
ignore, but this is a big
difference and it's something
that has to be kept track of.
So I think you're getting an
idea of the sort of filter that
ecosystem ecology places on the
details of other kinds of
biology.
Ecosystem ecology,
it's going to be interested in
keeping track of things that
make big differences to the flow
of energy and materials,
and it's going to say we
probably want to ignore the
rest,
just because life is complex
enough as it is.
Okay?
So this is really what's
driving that.
And that's why,
if you go back and you look at
those biomes,
you will see that when people
make biome classifications,
they keep track of whether
they're dealing with a
coniferous forest or a deciduous
forest,
and things like that.
Okay, if you look across the
world at grasslands,
forests and the open ocean,
you see a nice food pyramid.
And the green is the
herbivores--excuse me,
the green is the producers,
the yellow is the herbivores,
the red is the carnivores.
And if you just look at
biomass, you will see that in
grasslands you have a few big
fierce animals,
that are rare,
and then you've got a bunch of
grazing animals that are a bit
more common,
and there are more of them,
and then you've got a lot of
plants;
pretty much the same in the
forest.
Out in the open ocean it's
really quite different.
You have a few large top
predators;
so these are the tuna and the
sharks and the whales and things
like that.
Then you've got a big biomass
of herbivores,
and then not too many- not too
much biomass of the algae,
in the open ocean.
If you look at the energy flow
for the grasslands and the
forests, it's pretty similar to
the standing crop.
This would be the standing crop.
This is how much energy
calories per square meter per
day is flowing through it.
But in the open ocean something
is converting this kind of
anomalous picture into a sort of
standard food pyramid,
when you look at energy flow.
What's doing it?
What's the difference between a
grass and a single-celled alga?
Student: The algae are
more efficient.
>
Prof: Well you're
getting at it.
They are more efficient,
but they're more efficient in a
particular sense that makes a
big difference to rates.
Okay?
This is the difference--this is
a still photo and this is a
movie.
Okay?
So there's--that's the
difference.
It's a difference in rate.
Yes?
Student:  Algae
reproduce a lot faster.
Prof: That's basically
it, yes.
A single celled alga can
probably have two generations
per day and--
at least one per day--and maybe
even in a warm estuary three per
day,
whereas a grass is probably
going to be lucky to get through
two or three generations per
season.
Okay?
So there's a difference of
perhaps a hundredfold in the
rate.
And the things that are eating
them have a much,
much longer lifespan.
So down here what's going on is
that the algae,
there are not so many of them,
but they're cranking over like
crazy,
and they're getting harvested
like crazy by all of the
planktivores in the ocean.
So the krill,
the copepods,
everything that eats algae,
is grazing them,
and that's keeping the algae at
a fairly low level.
They're a long away from their
own carrying capacity.
They're in exponential growth
rate almost all the time.
So they're booming along,
and it doesn't take so much
standing crop to maintain a lot
more biomass because they are
turning over and reproducing and
multiplying so quickly.
So that is why you see this
dramatic shift.
Okay, so that's a bit of the
overall description of the
world's ecosystems.
Now let's take a look at cycles
of matter.
Okay?
The main compartments are
oceans, fresh water,
land and atmosphere,
and they are exchanging
materials all the time.
You're already familiar with
the upwelling patterns;
I've mentioned that when I was
discussing the Coriolis force.
So this is where the
nutrient-rich waters are coming
to the surface.
And in a place like the coast
of Peru,
you have millions and billions
of seabirds,
that are eating billions and
trillions of anchovies and
sardines,
that are feasting on trillions
and quadrillions of shrimp,
that are eating algae,
coming up there.
Okay?
So you have the cold Humboldt
current coming up and bending
offshore here,
heading out for the Galapagos,
and as it's moving out towards
the west--
in the Southern Hemisphere,
remember,
it is coming up towards the
equator;
the equator has a greater
angular velocity than the
southern part of South America,
and the water is getting kind
of left behind by the planet,
as the planet pulls out this
way.
And because you have a
continent here,
there's no water that's left
there to flow over and replace
it.
So the only place it can come
up from is the bottom,
and it comes up from the bottom
and fertilizes this zone off the
West Coast of South America.
Well over the course of
hundreds of millions of years
the seabirds that nest on
islands offshore,
so that they can get away from
the predators that would their
eggs on a continent,
have built up a huge deposit of
guano on the Chilean Islands.
And this was a matter of
international significance,
prior to the First World War,
because nitrogen was so
critical in the manufacture of
arms.
You remember the Oklahoma City
bombing,
when Timothy McVeigh simply
took nitrogen fertilizer and
mixed it with diesel fuel,
and put it into a truck and
blew up a building.
A lot of energy in nitrogen;
okay, nitrate, powerful stuff.
And this is where the world
supply was.
And, by the way,
that repeats at many other
upwelling areas around the
globe.
And just prior to World War
One, Haber and Bosch figured out
a way of fixing nitrogen from
the atmosphere,
as ammonia and urea--they did
it at high temperature and
pressure--
and that was actually what kept
Germany in the war between 1916
and 1918.
Okay?
So the reason I am mentioning
this is that I'm trying to use a
vivid example that shows you how
the flow of materials between
different compartments and
ecosystems has actually
influenced world history for
human culture.
And in this case it was
basically the seabirds taking it
out of the ocean and putting it
on land;
and putting it on in huge
quantities.
So now there's about 100
million tons of nitrogen
fertilizer produced every year.
It's about 1% of global
industrial energy,
and it sustains 40% of the
global human population.
So these kinds of processes
actually are part of the
substructure of our modern and
post-modern culture,
and it gives you some feel for
an ecosystem service.
Prior to the Haber-Bosch
process, this fixing of nitrogen
out of the atmosphere could only
be done by biological organisms,
and this is an estimate really
of how big that ecosystem
function was.
Okay, so let's run through some
of these cycles.
Almost all the nitrogen that's
on the surface of the planet is
biologically inaccessible;
it's in the form of
N_2.
N_2 is a molecule
that is extremely difficult to
react with.
And there are--it can be
converted into something that's
biologically accessible,
primarily by bacteria and by
cyanobacteria and by lightening.
So if you go out and simply
have a lightening storm pass
overhead,
and you compare the rain that
you get out of it,
with and without lightening,
in the five minutes or so after
a lightening strike directly
overhead,
if you're holding a cup out
there, you're going to be
getting nitrogen fertilizer.
It'll be fairly dilute,
but it's over a huge area.
Much more important are the
bacteria and cyanobacteria that
can convert nitrogen into
nitrate.
And most of that's going on in
the soil, okay?
So this is biological fixation.
It's bringing it down into the
soil.
It gets processed and
de-nitrified and goes back up as
N_2.
There's some industrial
fixation;
the Bosch-Haber process is
doing that.
This runs off,
gets into the ocean and
fertilizes the ocean.
If we look at the impact of
nitrate and sulfate on human
problems and on terrestrial
ecosystems, one of the big ones
is acid precipitation.
So this stuff right here,
all of human industry and cars
and so forth,
which in the United States has
been concentrated in an area
mostly roughly between Chicago
and Pennsylvania,
right here, this area,
because of the--
remember our Hadley cells and
the jet stream and the reason
that the air is flowing from
west to east across the
continent--
all of that emission is getting
picked up and it's getting
dropped on lakes in Canada and
the Northeastern United States.
So in 1955 the pH in this
region of the country,
in freshwater bodies,
had dropped to 4.6;
that's starting to get pretty
acid.
And by the way it was a much
bigger problem for a lake that
was sitting on granite than for
a lake that was sitting on
limestone.
Why would it be more of a
problem on granite than on
limestone?
Student:  Limestone's
basic.
Prof: Limestone's basic.
It's also a buffer.
So limestone will basically put
a lot of carbonate into the
water and buffer this.
So this was a big problem,
and in fact some lakes were
losing all of their fish
populations.
However, there were
improvements in air quality
control around the country,
and this has spread,
but in many places it's also
been ameliorated.
I'd say it still remains a
serious problem,
and it's a situation that also
causes international tensions,
because basically Eastern
Canada is getting hammered by
U.S.
industrial and car emissions,
because the flow of materials
around the planet does not
respect the arbitrary national
boundaries that humans have
created.
It's even worse in Europe.
In Europe the industrial
production of Germany,
which creates a huge load of
acid in the atmosphere,
gets dumped on Scandinavia,
which is old Scandinavian
basalt shield;
so they don't really have any
limestone buffer up there in
Scandinavia.
And that's one of the issues
that gets talked a lot about in
the European Union is how to
equalize these kinds of costs.
Because basically Canada is
being treated as an externality
by the United States,
and Scandinavia is being
treated as an externality by
Germany.
So that sort of thing needs
conflict resolution.
Okay, water.
The hydrological cycle is
critical because you can't grow
plants without water,
and you can't grow humans
without water either.
And as the human population has
gone up over five,
and now through six billion,
fresh water on the planet is
becoming very,
very scarce.
And, you know,
we think we have it tough in
this country because Arizona
keeps screaming that it needs
more water from California,
and California says no,
we're going to divert the
Columbia River down to Los
Angeles or something like that,
and the people that live in
Oregon get all up in arms.
But that is nothing compared to
the problems of the Middle East
and North Africa,
where water is actually one of
the ground- the basic reasons
for conflict among nations in
those areas.
And if you doubt that,
look at where the dams are that
Turkey has built on the
Euphrates and the Tigress,
and what that means for Iraq
and Syria.
Okay?
Or look at all of the issues
surrounding the
Israeli-Palestinian conflict,
which are many and cultural and
religious and many other things,
but they also have a lot to do
with water.
So the water cycle is really
quite critical.
And I want to just mention a
couple of things about it.
The standard issue with water
is that most of it's in the
ocean, and it evaporates from
the ocean;
of course, it evaporates more
when the oceans are warmer.
Remember the El Niño
effect--
right?--when that warm water
from the Western Pacific flows
back over towards the Eastern
Pacific,
then the evaporation of the
oceans increases,
you get a lot more water in the
atmosphere,
and rainfall goes up,
from the Galapagos to Arizona,
and right through to
Connecticut.
So the oceans are a very
important source of evaporation.
However evaporation off of
freshwater lakes is also
significant,
and anyone who lives in
Rochester or Buffalo will tell
you just exactly how significant
it is,
after they've had a three-foot
snowfall from lake effect snow--
right?--which is basically been
driven by this process.
So the water goes up and it
cycles through the rivers,
back into the ocean,
and long-term basically the
amount going in equals the
amount going out,
and as long as the West
Antarctic ice sheet doesn't
collapse,
or Greenland melts,
the level of the ocean stays
about the same.
By the way, the estimate on the
Antarctic ice sheets is that if
the ones that are currently
grounded melt,
that means there's an ice sheet
that's offshore,
but it's resting on the ocean
bottom.
And there are two big ones:
one is the Ross Sea ice shelf,
I think, and the other one is
an ice shelf on the other side
of the continent.
If those two melt,
then the ocean goes up about
ten meters, about thirty feet.
So the level of the ocean will
go up and down a bit.
So there's a very interesting
thing that's going on with
evapotranspiration out of
forests,
and I'm going to illustrate it
first with a picture and then
with a story about the Amazon.
Okay?
So if we go to the
Mediterranean,
and we look at the impact of
what the dairying culture did,
on the Mediterranean--so people
started keeping sheep and goats,
and goats are incredibly
efficient at removing brush and
grass from the landscape--
basically what the goats did is
that they desertified the
periphery of the Mediterranean,
all the way around.
They did it between about 5000
and 2000 years ago.
So if you back,
you can read in Greek and Roman
commentary about all of the
wonderful grain that was grown
in North Africa,
in places like Libya and in
Tunisia and Algeria,
and you can read descriptions
of the wild forested habitat of
Greece.
And you go to those places
today, many of them don't look
quite this desolate,
but they're certainly much more
like this than they are like a
nice deciduous forest or a
chaparral.
So goats had a big impact.
And you ask yourself,
"Well why does that
happen?"
Well we can actually,
by looking the Amazon
rainforest, we can get a pretty
clear idea of what was going on
in the periphery of the
Mediterranean.
So the transpiration from the
trees, in the Amazon,
is taking a huge amount of
water out of the soil and
putting it up into the
atmosphere every day.
So wherever you are in the
Amazon Basin,
usually by noon or about 2:00
in the afternoon,
you've got a cloud sitting over
your head,
and that's the water that came
out of the ground that day.
And there's also moisture,
of course, that's coming in
from the Atlantic,
and it's blown west,
up towards the Andes,
in the clouds.
And because of this
transpiration,
if you look at a molecule of
water that's coming in off the
South Atlantic,
by the time it hits the Andes
it's gone in and out four times;
it's rained four times by the
time it gets to the Andes.
So having the forest there is
making very efficient use of
that water.
It is a positive feedback loop
whereby the presence of the
forest is maintaining the
presence of the forest.
And if you cut down the forest,
the rainfall will decrease and
the total plant growth will
diminish,
and that will accelerate the
conversion of forest into
savanna.
So this is an extreme case of
that process.
In the Amazon there's enough
stuff coming in off of the South
Atlantic,
and it's at--remember if you
look at your Hadley cells,
it's in a region of the world
near the equator where you have
warm moist air rising.
So you're going to have
planetary forces generating
rainfall,
whether there are trees there
or not,
but you move just 30 degrees
north,
to the Mediterranean,
and you don't have that.
Here, at the Mediterranean,
you have got,
in your Hadley cell
circulation, you have got cold,
dry air falling,
and you don't get the planetary
forces regenerating and
replenishing the rainfall and
the forests that had been there
had been an important local
source of transpiration into the
atmosphere.
So at the equator this is what
you get, and boy is this stuff
efficient at getting water up
into the atmosphere.
One that a lot of you have read
a lot about I know is
atmospheric carbon dioxide and
greenhouse gasses and global
warming.
And it is the immediate source
of carbon for terrestrial
organisms, but it's really only
a tiny part of the global carbon
cycle.
So if we look at the carbon
cycle, and we look at storage in
gigatons of carbon--
the storage here is in black
and the flux in gigatons of
carbon is in purple.
So there's about 750 gigatons
of carbon in the atmosphere.
In the surface of the ocean
there's about 1000 gigatons.
In the deep ocean there's
38,000 gigatons of carbon,
and so forth.
Okay?
So vegetation has got a bit
less;
all the vegetation of the globe
has got a bit less carbon in it
than there is in the atmosphere,
and only about 1/50^(th) as
much as there is in the deep
ocean.
And there is carbon which is
moving between all these
compartments.
The fossil fuel and cement
production of the world has got
about 4000 gigatons stored,
and it's putting about 5
gigatons per year into the
atmosphere.
So if we look at that flux,
overall there's a big exchange
between the oceans and the
atmosphere.
There's a pretty big impact of
photosynthesis.
Plant respiration is putting
just about everything back into
the atmosphere that it's taking
out.
So this is pretty much a wash
right here.
The increment from fossil fuel
and land use looks pretty small
compared to the overall process.
But the critical thing is
whether or not at equilibrium
you're just pushing that
equilibrium a little bit,
because these are rates,
and rates accumulate.
Back in about 1955 or so,
a forward thinking atmospheric
scientist started measuring the
carbon dioxide in the world's
atmosphere right here at 11,000
feet on Mauna Loa on the big
island of Hawaii.
And he chose that because there
you're about 2500 miles out from
any continent.
The atmosphere has been well
mixed by the trade winds,
and you're going to get a very,
very well mixed sort of
standard signal that's not
contaminated by any local
industry or anything like that.
This is what it looks like.
This is the Mauna Loa direct
measurement signal over here,
and these are inferences of
past levels of carbon dioxide
concentration in the atmosphere.
This is parts per million by
volume in the atmosphere,
over here.
And you can see that there's a
signal that human industrial
activity has been increasing
carbon dioxide level arguably
since the late nineteenth
century--
okay?--and it's accelerating
upward.
These are from ice core
measurements that are done
mostly in Greenland by Danes and
Swiss who go to Greenland and
bore down through the icecap.
Now let's put that in
perspective, okay?
So this is today and this is
500 million years ago,
and these are all different
kinds of measurements of carbon
dioxide through the last 550
million years.
And the 30 million year filter
is--this is a moving average,
a 30 million year moving
average--and basically what it
shows is that most of the time
the earth has had a lot more
carbon dioxide in its atmosphere
than it currently has;
much more than anything that
has been contributed by human
activity and industry in the
last 150 years.
This is estimated by various
different methods,
and it has a couple of striking
features.
Look what happens to carbon
dioxide between the Ordovician
and the Carboniferous.
It is sucked out of the
atmosphere.
Where do you think it went?
Student: Over there.
Prof: Some.
Some went into reefs.
It went into your gas tank.
That's when oil and coal were
made.
So when land plants first
evolved--and that was when- that
was the first big forest,
planet covering forest,
and it was warm and moist--
in those carboniferous swamps,
you know,
generation after generation,
for thousands of generations of
plants, built up.
Then there's an interesting
re-injection of carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere in the
Permian,
and it happens particularly at
the end-Permian crisis,
and this re-injection then does
have the oceanic element.
Okay?
So some of that stuff did get
stored,
like in the Black Sea,
right here, and then with the
end-Permian extinction and the
breakup of Pangaea and the
re-ordering of the oceanic
circulation patterns it got
re-injected.
Then throughout the
Mesozoic--so throughout the time
that the earth was dominated by
dinosaurs and their other
relatives--
it was pretty warm and plants
could really grow.
They were getting--by the way,
carbon dioxide is a fairly good
fertilizer;
so plants do grow more rapidly
when they have more of it,
if they aren't being limited by
some other nutrient.
And then when we get into the
last 65 million years,
here, carbon dioxide is going
down,
down, down, until we get to
what we perceive as the normal
concentration--
right?--the normal
concentration being down here.
Well it was a lot higher,
for a long period of time.
I think there's an important
message in that.
The important message is that
at the scale of life on the
planet, global warming is
trivial.
Life has dealt with it and will
deal with it just fine.
There will be extinctions,
but life will not go extinct
because of global warming.
There's been plenty of species
that could deal with much warmer
conditions on the planet,
and those kinds of things will
increase in abundance as things
warm.
However that doesn't mean that
global warming is not important.
Global warming is especially
important because of sea level
rise,
and because of the increase in
variation in weather patterns,
which means that both periods
of drought and floods will
become more frequent at
intermediate latitudes,
and the intensity and the
number of major storms will
probably increase.
It would be interesting to know
what the hurricane strength was
like back in the Silurian.
You know?
Katrina might have been just a
little blip, compared to a
Silurian hurricane,
but unfortunately we don't know
how big they were.
Now the fate of the carbon that
was in the original planetary
atmosphere can be sketched here.
And basically what you see is
that it's mostly in limestone
and in sediment,
and there's a huge chunk of it
sitting in the ocean as
bicarbonate.
So think about that the next
time you buy a bottle of soda
water or sparkling water.
That's representative of 37 or
38,000 gigatons of carbon.
Fossil fuel,
organic sediment and so forth,
you find that there's dissolved
CO_2,
which actually is the molecule
and not as the bicarbonate ion,
in the ocean.
Living biomass, fairly small;
methane in the atmosphere
pretty small.
So when you look at that,
you wonder well where is the
biggest source of carbon that
might get mobilized into the
atmosphere?
And in fact it's in methane
hydrate.
Okay?
Methane hydrate will be a solid
in cold water but it will melt
and release methane with just a
little increase in temperature.
Okay?
It turns out there's about 100
trillion cubic meters of methane
hydrate stockpiled around the
planet,
sitting there in sediments,
ready to be mobilized.
So if the world's oceans warm
up by a few degrees,
there will be a very dramatic
positive feedback effect as this
methane comes bubbling out.
And methane is a more efficient
greenhouse gas than carbon
dioxide, by quite a bit.
So its contribution to global
warming could triple and really
accelerate, if things warm up.
And this is just a picture
showing you that methane hydrate
is stored in places like the
sediments underneath deep water.
So you have,
say in the Arctic,
it will be fairly shallow;
off Louisiana it will be fairly
deep.
But there's a lot of it.
The phosphorous cycle is
different from the carbon and
nitrogen cycles because
phosphorous doesn't have a
gaseous phase.
It's a solid or a liquid.
And it's the scarcest essential
element.
Of course, we need it for ATP,
we need it to build the
phosphate sugar backbone of DNA,
and we need it for energy
transmission and so forth;
all life needs it for that.
But it is really pretty scarce
in the crust.
So it is usually limiting.
Now if you just go out there
and you pour a bunch of
phosphate into the landscape,
this is what you get.
Okay?
You get lakes filled with algal
blooms,
and that is showing you the
dramatic response of--
the algal population and plant
population in lakes is showing
you that phosphorous really is
the limiting factor.
So phosphate fertilizer is very
important in agro-ecosystems,
and phosphate fertilizer gets
washed into lakes and fish die.
Why do fish die in an eutrophic
lake that has a lot of algae in
it?
What's killing them?
Yes?
Student: Because when
the algae becomes decomposed,
those >
will take a lot of it and
change it into nitrogen.
>
Prof: Well you've got it
right about anoxia,
but you got the mechanism
wrong.
By the way, the bottom of a
eutrophic lake is anoxic and the
process you described is going
on there.
But the algae don't have to die
to do that.
Student:
>
Prof: Well the algae
certainly are taking the
sunlight out of the top of the
water.
But when does the oxygen
disappear from the lake?
I remember the bad joke about
the astronaut who was not so
bright,
who said, "Ah,
we are going to take our new
spacecraft and we are going to
land on the sun."
And he was asked,
"How are you ever going to
land on the sun?"
And he said,
"Don't worry,
we are going at night."
It happens at night.
At night the algae are all
there.
They're not making oxygen
because there's no photons
coming in,
but they still have to breathe
themselves,
and they just suck all the
oxygen out of the water and the
fish are asphyxiated.
They don't have to die to do it.
They're just naturally living
their lives as normal healthy
algae and they suck the oxygen
out of the water at night.
Okay, so some take-home points
on ecosystems.
Movement of matter and energy
around the planet is really
important, and there are some
really interesting large-scale
issues.
And if you like big numbers and
you like to calculate and look
at flow models and compartment
models and differential
equations and stuff like that,
biogeochemistry has a place for
you.
The contact here is with
geology, physical chemistry and
meteorology.
The connections are important.
They're not all well worked out.
So there must be important
connections between ecosystem
ecology and community ecology,
but they are still being
explored, and this is not an
area that's really mature yet.
The part of ecology that
analyses these processes really
is the part that deals with the
fate of the planetary
environment,
especially water and air,
and that means it has important
economic and political
implications.
So it's an area well worth
worrying about and learning
something about and remembering,
because these are the processes
that will affect the quality of
human life on the planet,
for forever basically.
Okay, next time I'm going to
discuss biodiversity,
and about whether it matters or
not, and about what extinctions
mean.